This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. We have a special guest on for this episode. And I'm going to say I've been,
this was one of the first content creators slash podcasters I ever was a huge fan of. Back in the day of the early stages of YouTube. So it feels like a full circle moment to bring her on to talk everything, dating, moving to a big city, work, life, relationships. In our 20s, she has an amazing perspective.
So welcome, Katie. Hello, everyone. Thanks for having me. Absolutely. I feel like this is obviously a show about our 20s, and your, like, content really, I think, encapsulates a lot of what we're going through. If you don't know who Katie is,
she is a YouTuber, podcaster, content creator, also freelance graphic designer, is that correct? Yep. Yep. Yes, that's what I studied in college. That's what I'm like technically trained to do, but I do a lot of other things too on top of that. Yeah, which we like. You've got to have like diversity. You've got to diversify the career portfolio when you're young. And so I, the reason I really wanted to bring you on, like I said before, is, you know, a lot of your content has for me really highlighted what my 20 should be like as someone who's also highlighting that for other people. So it's like really interesting to see how, you know,
even when you talk about this every single day, you still sometimes need like other people to look to to be like, am I doing this right? Like, should I be doing something else? Oh, of course. What's going on? Imposter syndrome 101, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Have you, I'm sure you've experienced that so much given, you've been like on the internet since you were like 14, 15. Yeah, 14, 2009 made my first YouTube video. still up somewhere in the depths of the internet. But oh, of course, I've gone through so many phases with this. And I think especially with the emergence of TikTok, that really threw me for a loop. Like I entered that. And it's been a while since I was just extremely bad at social media. Like I always thought of myself as being the one that's good at social media. You know,
like I've, you know, grown this audience on YouTube and it translated into Instagram. And I even got a corporate job for a hot second that really was, you know, the reason for that job was because I was well-versed in social media. And then TikTok comes along. I start my account thinking, oh, I'm going to be, not, you know, to shoot my own horn, but I'm like, I'm good at creating content. Oh, my God. It took me probably a good six months just to learn how to use the app and be able to do like, you know, the sounds and and line up my mouth with the words. And oh, my God, props to everybody who like starts on TikTok, it's such a craft, like that I'm still learning. So yeah, imposter syndrome to the max, always. Oh, I can absolutely imagine. Because I'm in the same boat.
I cannot stand. Well, I love TikTok as a user, but I absolutely hate it as like a content creator. Oh, yeah. And so I don't even, I, it's, I just feel such like a pressure, like a pressure and a sense of, of dread and like, oh, if I'm not, if I'm not doing, if I'm not doing, if I'm on TikTok, like I'm not going to get as many opportunities. And for me, it's been like this whole mentality of being like, actually, you know what you're good at. You do this thing that's, you do well, and you really like doing it. And you don't like making TikToks and you don't like being too out there on social media. So it's like, how about you just focus on that and not try and be like in everything. You know what I mean? Right. I think we struggle with that as people that are like multi-hyphenate types
that consider themselves to be more than just one thing. Like I'm not, you know, an architect or a lawyer like on the social media creator there's so many different kinds of social media that you're working on it and so it feels like you have to do it all all the time oh my goodness yeah and you can't just be like it's so interesting if you i was like at this party the other day and someone was like what do you do for work what do you say to that what do you say to that well this was like everyone in the room was like a finance bro every single one of them was worked for like an investment capital i don't even know what what it's called And so I say one of two things.
Either I say I work in radio because that's, right? Like people could, people have like a relational narrative around what radio is and radio presenters. Or I just say that I'm an entertainer. But then I realized that that has other connotations the other day. Yeah. So like an adult entertainer. It's a bit vague.
Bit vague. Yeah. And it's like, so you're not a musician. You're not an actor. You're an entertainer. you a clown? Like, um, yeah. Because when you say like, I'm, I'm a content creator, you say I'm a podcaster.
Yeah. People do not know how to respond to that. It's one of those things where like I said, multi-hyphen it. It's like, I'm a podcaster, YouTuber, Instagram or occasional TikToker, tried threads for two days. You know, it's like you just dip your toe. You're a multi-hyphenate, like so many hyphenes. So I, I actually said like, I mean, I think about it as far as like what's on or what was on my hinge profile. I said social media.
occupation social media I work in social media typically when you say that there aren't too too many questions like it's like oh okay she probably works for an agency or like with people I hardly know I'm like I don't really need to give you the whole spiel unless you care to know more you know it's like yeah yeah the other thing that I think you talk about which I found really relatable which I said to you before I know has now changed um is your kind of approach to dating slash, I would say some of the milestone anxiety around the fact that you hadn't really ever had a boyfriend until very recently. Can you talk us through? There's a few stages to this that I think are really fascinating because I think that a lot of people message me and they're like,
how do I deal with this stigma, this anxiety, this desperation almost that I've never dated someone, everyone around me has, and I'm lonely. And I feel. like I'm missing out and I feel like there's something wrong with me. Can you kind of talk through what that, if you had that experience? Maybe you did it. Oh my goodness. Yes, I have. Yes, I have. I mean, it's evident in my content because I've, of course, filmed my whole life for the past 14, 15 years. And so like I go back and now I've been in this relationship, new relationship for three weeks now. I've met him two months ago on a dating app after 27 years of being single. 27 years of situation ships, of course, you know, a few month long flings where, you know,
you don't really even know what happened. One night stands going on a second date thinking it went great, getting ghosted. Like I have experienced probably everything possible in the realm of failed dating experiences. Like, you know, I've been the one to cut things off. Like I just wasn't feeling. I think it's one of those things where I grew up very, this is such a great thing. thing, but it has definitely affected the way that I live in love. My parents have the most beautiful love. Like the most beautiful love story, the way they met, the way they fell in love.
Like there's this whole like fairy tale feeling to it. And growing up like my parents never fought their best friends. Like they make fun of each other. They still like make out in front of my sister and I. We think it's like the most disgusting thing ever, but in the best way obviously because we're great we feel grateful because you know I have so many friends that their parents are divorced or they have you know there's just been problems in their parents relationship and so for me I'm like I'm so grateful for that but it definitely has kind of bled into my love life in the sense of like I'm comparing everybody like I didn't personally have any previous relationships to compare you know I'm in this new relationship now I have nothing previous to compare it to the only thing that I've ever
compared anything to is my parents love and it's It's one of those things where I'm, like, so grateful that I have parents that are in love. But it also, like, every time I go on a date or have gone on dates, in the back of my mind, there's that nagging little, like, well, like, will you love them? Like, your parents love each other. So then, you know, that's definitely been in the back of my mind, my whole, my whole dating journey, you know? It's very interesting what you point to there, which is that our first example of love is the relationship we have with our caregivers. and if we have parents that are still together,
the relationship that they have with each other. That is like our only blueprint, our only blueprint. Everyone is just following on from really what they saw in their childhood. And it's interesting because we know about, you know, attachment styles and things like that. But I think that we often talk about, you know, anxious attachment, dismissive, avoidant. But there are elements of a secure attachment as well that still make it hard to date and the fairy tale narrative and not wanting to settle but then having everyone be like well you're never going to find anyone with those standards right i heard i heard that so often i still
like i don't hear it anymore because obviously i have a boyfriend now but i hear it i used to hear it all the time where i'd be like oh is it really that much to ask that this person like treats me really, really well. Yeah. And is it, yeah, is it really that much to us that like I get flowers every now and again? Like what? Yeah. I mean, I think I'm definitely in, in terms of just how I love, even in my platonic relationships, like I love hard. Like I love, I don't love halfway. Like if I, you know, if I meet someone and I don't particularly mesh well with them, like, it's pretty obvious from the get-go because I, you know, when I like really latch on to someone and like I definitely have one of those types of attachment styles where like I'm always thinking about everybody that
I love like at all times of the day like a close friend of mine first day of work today I think she thought everyone forgot I'm texting her first thing and it's not not trying to say like oh I'm such a great person like whatever that's just the way I love and so it's tough when you you know you go into situationships or when you're ghosted and you don't receive that back like the reason why I chose or you know of course he chose me mutual choosing me being in this new relationship with this guy that I met on the stating app. I'm not disclosing his name yet. That's like the one thing I'm keeping under wraps. Keep it to yourself. So I'm going to refer to him as my boyfriend. But it's also so weird saying that. Like I haven't, you know, 27 years have never said,
oh, my boyfriend. Like this is so and so my boyfriend. So weird. But the reason why I've decided to finally choose him, like after years of being picky, years of not settling, even though people are like, hey, your standards are too high is because he gives me back. Like, he gives me what I need. I give him what he needs. And we have this like, it feels like a friendship, but just like times a million. It's like we have this great banter all the time. It's not just like when we're drinking, you know, which I feel like when I was dating. It was, you know, a lot easier after a few like gin and tonics like in the beginning.
But no, I like I feel like we have this like kindred spirits vibe. That is the kindred spirits. Like I feel like I've known him forever. And I've never felt. that before and I see parts of that like in my parents love which is comforting but I also I think through the years of doing this have realized like my love is not going to be the same as my parents love because you know I I don't I didn't grow up in the 80s this you know the 70s the 80s and times are different like I was really beating myself up for a minute there when I met this guy on this
on a dating app I was like no no I don't want to do it that way I wanted to meet him in person And I wanted to be at a coffee shop and he asked me what book I'm reading. Like that's what I wanted. But, you know, we live in a different age now. So the fairy tale story is going to look a little different, but it doesn't mean that it doesn't feel the same. Yeah. And I think it's like, I know.
I do know what you mean. It's like having a good story. Like I think me and my ex had a great story. Our like first time meeting was like was out of a fairy tale. And like I've talked about it before, but like I was his waitress at a bar on his 21st birthday. they and he was there with his mom and his mom ended up giving me his number when they left and it was like to be and like ran back in and gave me the number and he didn't know and basically it was this whole beautiful story that didn't change the trajectory of our love right it which is
so interesting it actually it it was a nice story and it was nothing more because if the relationship isn't good you know a story is only as good as long as you can tell it and once you've broken up you can't tell it anymore because do you know what I mean the content of the relationship isn't great I just got chills like hearing that you're so right really yeah it's like at some point you know the story ends and it's not something you talk about it's either yeah there's this Taylor Swift song the story of us and she's like you know kind of discussing like what will our story be will it be like love or an end and you know that was that song was made so long ago I wonder if she even thinks about that story anymore You know, it's interesting.
That's a really good question. Let's give her a call. Call her up. Why don't you just call Taylor up? I was like, is she going to say it or am I going to say it? No, one of us has to say it. Yeah, no. Yeah, like, and I think it's interesting because our stories now have a lot of parallels.
And I really weighed, like, after my last relationship ended, I was like, I'm not doing this anymore. I'm not doing situationships anymore. I'm not doing one-sided. anything. And I made like this list of like what I was looking for. Did you have a list of like non-negotiables or did you just know them? I just know them. I there was a point living in New York. I mean, there's a lot of opportunities here because there's a lot of people here and a lot of single people here, especially in your 20s. I feel like people oftentimes don't settle down here until they're in their like mid-30s and it's completely natural and normal like in the city. It's just kind of,
it's not like a shocking thing to hear, oh, like yeah, they're getting married at 36. like, you know, and that, not to say that's old, but, you know, my mom and dad got married 27, 28. So you always kind of have this like freak out moment because I'm 27 now turning 28 in October. So I'm like, oh, my God. But New York does give you that comfort of like, oh, I have time. So that's like a plus of living here. I feel like people, you know, career first, having fun first, which can always, you know, can be a positive or a negative depending on how you look at it.
But I know, but I, it's this thing of like milestone anxiety. where it's like, yes, right? And it's so cultural and like societal and contextual because I like, it's so interesting that you're talking about how in New York it's like everyone, they commit a little bit later. They have,
they feel like they have more of this, this like time carved out for freedom. But like amongst the people that I'm around, I would say the majority of them are in their early 20s and either live with or have a very serious partner. Oh, yeah. Especially like it. in Australia, I think, but also in the places outside of the major cities.
Yeah. Look, I have friends who, like, moved in with their boyfriends at, like, 22. Got engaged like 23, 21. Oh, yeah. People from my hometown. Absolutely. Facebook was a scary place, like, for a few years there for me. I mean, even still, like, it's like, I open it up.
I'm like, oh, another baby, another engagement. And look at me. But, yeah, New York definitely has that element of, I think people, you know, there's not as much of a rush. Granted, I always, as a woman, feel like there's a bit of a rush. Like, you know, you always, I'm already looking into, you know, maybe when I turn 30, that's what I, you know, I freeze my eggs. Like, I, I'm not ready for that right now. But your question about, like, did I have, like, a checklist or something when I was, like, going on dates?
No, but there was a point there when I was going on, like, actually two, potentially three dates a week. Like, I was just plowing through it. I mean, not that I was, like, desperate to find him or whatever, but mostly because everyone's doing it. which I think is like really, really quite like valuable, right? Because I feel like when I was single, I always felt this pressure to like to meet someone and to be like, and to be like my friends, right? To be like happily with someone at 23. But then I also have this mentality of like, is that actually what I want right now?
Because I really like being single. And I like that I have my independence and I like that I. I'm able to do my own thing. And it wasn't that like someone's going to detract from that, but it's like if I'm going to add another person in here, they better be really, really worth it. And it's like interesting that I think from a lot of those experiences I had where I was dating people who like wouldn't commit or who were like quite awful or who,
um, you know, would ghost me like you said after like a couple of dates or I would, you know, unfortunately ghost them or. And it was like, kind of sick of being treated like a second option or I'm sick of being treated poorly and I took like six months I took six months off um from dating and I was like I'm going to give the dating apps one more try like I'm just going to do it one more time and I was like you know when you like are on dating
um, you know, would ghost me like you said after like a couple of dates or I would, you know, unfortunately ghost them or. And it was like, kind of sick of being treated like a second option or I'm sick of being treated poorly and I took like six months I took six months off um from dating and I was like I'm going to give the dating apps one more try like I'm just going to do it one more time and I was like, you know when you like are on dating
apps and you're like I don't actually really want to talk to anyone yep yep I just feel like I need to be there I wanted yeah I've I've been in that realm as well where I just like want like a little confidence boost I'm like, oh, all these people like me? Amazing. I'm going to do nothing with this. I'm not going to reach out to a single person. Wait, are you teeing up the fact that was the last date you went on, like the last date in your mind, you're like, oh, this is my last one, was when you met your boyfriend?
Yeah. I wasn't tearing it up. Oh, my God, really? Yeah. So actually crazy enough. I don't know if I, like, fully believe in all of this, but a year ago, May, 2022, I went to see a psychic, with my friend Colby, who you know from the podcast from Matchmade, went to see a psychic. Like we were just having a drunk night, got pizza, psychic was right there.
You know, why don't we just pop in? See what she has to say. Got my palm red, did the whole thing, was giggling the whole time. She goes, in a year's time, you are going to meet the love of your life. And I'm like, okay, lady, sure. Like, sure. I just got chills. That was May 22.
May 2020. three, not too long ago, I set on my podcast, guys, I'm so sick of the dating apps. I'm so sick of situation ship after situation ship. So sick of me even going on dates and being like I am, I'm just like not clicking with people. Like I'm so sick of this. Like I, it's summer. I'm going to go on one last hinge date of summer.
I'm deleting the app after that. Like I just need a break. I wasn't like, this is when I'm going to meet the person. I was like, I just need a break. I matched with my now boy. friend May 2023 a year after I saw the psychic. And it's crazy because I didn't even remember this. A podcast listener pointed this out to me. I completely forgot about this psychic experience. I mean, I was like drunk and it was a year ago and like, you know, time flies. A lot, a lot of
dates since then. But yeah, and now we're official and I'm dating him. Isn't that crazy? It is. I actually not chose when you said that like a year later. And the fact that you're like, like this lady, she just wants to sell, you know, the extended package for more palm ratings. I mean, she probably did, but like, alas, it ended up being kind of cute. Yeah, but it's like, it's so funny when you're like, you have that skepticism. And I think it's really, so I have this theory, right, is that when you are finally at your wits end slash, like, highly skeptical, your guard is most up. And so you're better able to actually discern someone's character.
and also you're not looking for it. And when I was single, I absolutely hated the phrase. It will come when you least expect it. Oh my God. Don't even get me started on that one. Don't even get me started. I was like, I am a very... People love to say that.
Yeah. They love to say that. I will never say that to anyone. Me neither. Because I remember how it felt to hear that. 27 years of being single, like, oh, my God, you know. Yeah. It's a tough one.
Also, when people say that, that they're like, you know, it'll happen when you least expect it. It's like, I'm a very anxious person. I'm always expecting everything. Like that is the... No, I'm a hopeless romantic. I'm always expecting a love story to happen every day of my life. I fall in love six times a day with people on the street. So like, no, I'm always expecting it. So am I just never going to find love? Like, is that, you know? Exactly. And I'm also like, that is ridiculous because you can be very intentional and meet someone amazing. Like, you can be set up. Like, it's, I, I hate that. It's a numbers game. It is a numbers game like we were talking about.
It's a number's game. It's interesting because like when you were just discussing your new boo and how you were like, I'm going to go on one more date. Same thing. This is kind of crazy. And also I have not really spoken about this on the podcast. I'm kind of like hard launching here. Ooh, okay.
But he's, I've talked to him about it. So like I know he's fine with it. And he's probably listening right now because he's a good boy and listens to all my episodes. But it was really interesting. because I had been in Bali, actually. And while I was in Bali, which is like the Australian version of going to like Mexico,
like going to like Cancun, like you go to Bali. Yeah. And I was there with like a bunch of people who were like freshly single. I mean like straight out of relationships and they were like ready to get it on essentially. And they were like, we're in Bali. Let's like have heaps of sex and go on heaps of dates. And I was like, oh my God, I feel really left out. I was like, I've got phomo.
yeah, I want to do that. And so I downloaded it and I matched with one person and that was him. And then... Chills. Chills, chills. But then I ghosted him, which is, yeah, because I was in Bali and I had lost my phone and I was just like, I'm having the best time. Define ghost, how long?
It was like two days, three days. Oh, okay. And he'd like, ask, well, it wasn't great. And I like, it's a soft ghost. It's a soft ghost. And it was interesting as well. Yeah, because you technically ghosted your man as well. Oh, for a full week, he spelled my name wrong.
Of course I did. I said, you come back. I'd like send him to time out. You come back. I'm going to give you a no reply. Come back when you've learned your lesson and you can spell my name right. Because I'm not going on a date with someone who doesn't know how to spell my name. Yeah, no.
That's absolutely the bare minimum. The bare minimum. But I like, I like, yeah, I ghosted him and he like asked me this amazing question. and he like he came he was like I don't like small talk I'm going to ask you 10 questions about like yourself wow how thrilling yeah yeah but I'm going to say best dating advice ever if you're a guy listening to this which I'm guessing there's not many of you but if there are you getting a really amazing golden nugget of advice here do that ask the questions straight away cut through the small talk and it was so impressive and then we went and then I came back and I was like I'm so sorry I goes to do all this things
happened. I also ran into an ex while I was over there, which was actually, it was closure, though. I was like, oh, my God. I think it was like the final thing because I hadn't really been committed to dating because I was still so upset and like hurt by what this person had done to me. And then I saw him again and I was like, yeah, right, we're done with that. I was like, done, moving on. And then I was like, all right, let's go on a date. And I went on the date and I was like, same reaction. I was like, wow, I was like, this is such bad timing for this to be happening right now. Because I was like, this is what it's going to be. And I was like, this is just terrible timing.
So I was like, I'm about to move. All this stuff is happening. But I think in terms of your story, I really find that it would be highly relatable to people who message me and are like, I've never had a boyfriend, right? And we feel a lot of pressure around that, which we've spoken about. What kind of advice would you give to them now kind of on the other side, right? It's such a thrilling story to be like to see that transition. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, of course, I've struggled with it. You know, it's been 27 years of occasionally feeling like, wow, look at me. I'm proud of myself. I'm proud of myself for not settling.
I'm proud of myself for not entering a relationship with someone that I just knew in my bones was not right. I'm proud of myself for sticking to my guns. But then Valentine's Day rolls around. Or, you know, you see a TikTok of people who met when they were 22 and then fell in love. already have three babies by 27 where I am now. And you start comparing yourself. And, you know, it's one of those things where it's, there's really good days of like, wow, look at me go. I'm proud of myself.
我为自己没有和那些我内心深处明知不对的人谈恋爱而感到自豪。我为自己能坚持原则而感到自豪。但随后情人节就到了。或者，你知道的，你会在TikTok上看到一些人，他们22岁相遇然后相爱，到27岁时——也就是我现在这个年纪——就已经有了三个宝宝。然后你就开始自我比较。而且，你知道的，这其实就是那种有时感觉很好，觉得“哇，看我多棒，我为自己感到自豪”的日子。
Like, you know, I have this epic career that I've crafted from the ground up, you know, this job that I have that has like been my life that I'm so passionate about. And yet I get like into this, this funk of like, oh, but I'm single. But like, it's like, oh, I'm like, oh, one day my life will be completely. when I have everything, when I have it all. And of course, you know, you lean on like the TV shows. Carrie Bradshaw said like in New York, you're always looking for three things. A boyfriend, an apartment, or a job.
就像，你知道的，我有一份自己从零开始打造的史诗般的事业，你知道的，这份工作就像是我的生命一样，我对它充满了热情。然而，我又陷入了一种沮丧之中，觉得“哦，但我还是单身”。但随后又会想，“哦，总有一天，当我拥有一切、拥有一切的时候，我的生活就会完全不同了”。当然，你知道的，你会依赖那些电视剧。凯莉·布莱德肖曾在纽约说过，你总是在寻找三样东西：一个男朋友、一套公寓，或者一份工作。
And I'm like, well, I have two. I have a fabulous West Village apartment that I'm like so proud that I'm unhappy with myself that I'm able to live here. And I have a great job. But then there was always that missing piece. And I always, of course, you know, I'm one of those types of thinkers. I like to look into the why. I'm very curious, have always been.
而我想，好吧，我有两样。我有一套极棒的西村公寓，我为自己能住在这里感到无比自豪和开心。我还有一份很棒的工作。但总觉得生命中还缺了那么一块。当然，我一直以来都是这种爱思考的人。我喜欢探究原因。我一直都非常好奇。
I'm assuming a lot of people listen to your podcast also are very curious. And it's a blessing but also a curse because you tend to want to know the reason for everything. So I looked at myself of a single girl at 27 and I'm like, okay, let's just go through all the things that must be wrong with me because like there has to be. I'm like, you know, there has to be because I look at my friends. and I'm like, oh, well, you know, they have a boyfriend, but this is how they are different than me. And this, maybe I should be less present on social media. Maybe that's a turnoff. And you also, like, kind of take with you every negative thing that's ever been said about you,
我猜听你播客的很多人也都非常好奇。这既是一种福气，也是一种诅咒，因为你往往想知道每件事背后的原因。所以我审视了自己27岁单身女孩的状态，然后我想，好吧，让我们来盘点一下我身上肯定存在的所有毛病，因为肯定是有原因的。我想，你知道的，肯定有的，因为我看着我的朋友们。然后我想，哦，好吧，你知道的，她们有男朋友，但这正是她们与我不同的地方。或者这个，也许我应该减少在社交媒体上的活跃度。也许那会让人反感。而且你还会不由自主地把别人对你说过的每一句负面评价都带在身上，
especially by a man, if you are interested in men. Like, I, everything, every negative thing a guy has ever said to me, like, lives on me, like, you know, a tattoo. Like, I haven't forgotten. Third grade, Harry Arms. that was like my biggest insecurity. Someone said that to in third grade? Someone
尤其是如果你的兴趣是男性的话，男人对你说的那些话。就像我，一个男人对我说过的每一句负面评价，都像文身一样留在我身上，你知道的。我都没有忘。三年级时，有人说我的手臂汗毛重。
like yes early on pointed out the hairy arms and so you know of course I'm like mom I need to shave I need to shave and she's like I'm not shaving arms years later I do shave my arms now and I'm like it's like it was one of those things I made the decision in college but of course
那可以说是我的最大心结。有人在三年级时对你说过这个？有人
I still remember all of that so it's one of those things where you never forget and you use those things to hurt yourself when you're in those moments of like maybe I'm not the most powerful, most amazing girl in New York. Maybe I'm just, there's something wrong with me and you feel lonely. But I have to say, like being on, quote, the other side of it now, like, oh, you know, I am, I'm 27 with my first boyfriend. It's all very new and very exciting and, but also very much like, I still think to myself, you know, did I make the right decision?
就像是的，很早就有人指出了手臂汗毛重的问题，所以你知道的，我当然会跟我妈说：“我需要刮毛，我需要刮毛。”而她却说：“我才不刮手臂上的毛呢。”多年以后，我现在确实会刮手臂上的毛了，我想，这就好像是我在大学时做出的一个决定，但当然了，我依然记得所有这些。所以这就属于那种你永远不会忘记的事情，每当陷入那种“也许我并不是纽约最强大、最了不起的女孩，也许我只是身上有什么毛病，也许我很孤独”的时刻，你就会用这些事情来伤害自己。但我必须承认，当真正站在了所谓的“另一面”时，比如，“哦，你知道的，我27岁了，有了第一个男朋友。”这一切都非常新鲜、非常令人兴奋，但同时也是一种，“我仍然会忍不住想，我做出正确的决定了吗？”
Like, did I? But then I remind myself, I'm like, I'm not getting married. Oh, no. So it's like there is, you know, you get into the relationship and it's not like all of your worries end, you know? Yeah. I think that's the one takeaway that I'm feeling. It's like be picky, don't settle. Don't listen to people that are like your standards are too high.
就像，我真的做对了吗？但转念一想，我又提醒自己，我又不是在结婚。哦，不。所以这就意味着，当你进入一段恋爱关系时，并不意味着你所有的担忧都会烟消云散，对吧？是的。我想这是我最大的感悟。那就是要挑剔一点，不要将就。不要听信那些说你标准太高的人的话。
Not true. I mean, you're not going to find a perfect person. I think we're all aware of that. And being someone that was told that, don't settle. Like, you know, don't or do settle pretty much. Like, you know, you need some experience on your belt. No. BS. Like I, my boyfriend now has had girlfriends in the past, not super recently, but like in the
根本不是真的。我的意思是，你不可能找到一个完美的人。我想我们都心知肚明。而且作为一个曾经被人劝告说“不要将就”的人——或者说，你知道的，其实就是劝你“差不多得了，去将就一下吧，你知道的，你得积累点恋爱经验”。扯淡。就像我，我现在的男朋友过去也谈过女朋友，虽然不是最近的事，但确实是在
past. And I think the best thing has just been super honest, like being super honest up front with him being like, hey, he was fully aware before he asked me that this was going to be my first. He's taken it very seriously, but been very like gentle with it. And he's like, so find someone that's like that. Oh, yeah. Honestly, they're out there. They exist. They really do. I don't know. the ones that like want they want to commit they want the commitment from you like they want you know to have that like label but not for the wrong reasons and yeah it's just been it's been a learning experience all of it he knows everything everything that i've always been insecure to share especially having this career where my life is my job and posting about it and he's been so
过去。我觉得最好的做法就是对他超级坦诚，从一开始就坦诚相告，告诉他：“嘿，他在向我表白之前就完全清楚，这将是我的初恋。”他对此非常认真，但同时也处理得非常温柔。他说，所以，去找一个像这样的人吧。哦，是的。说实话，这样的人是存在的。他们真的存在，千真万确。我不知道。那些想要承诺的人，他们想要你给他们承诺，他们想要你知道的拥有那种“名分”，但不是出于错误的理由。是的，这一切都是一个学习的过程。他了解我的一切，了解我一直以来羞于分享的一切，尤其是考虑到我的职业——我的生活就是我的工作，还要把这些发到网上分享，而他在这一点上一直做得
great with that like with not worrying last night he was was like, so I think some of your followers found me on LinkedIn. I'm like, I follow about 3,000 people on Instagram. I also don't even like use my LinkedIn. So I don't, I don't know how they could possibly do it, but people are very smart. Anyway, so I was like in horror sitting at this bar listening to him talk about, oh, like I think a couple people like found me on LinkedIn. But he's not saying it in like a proud way. He's saying it in just a matter of fact, like this is what happened. And I was waiting for him to be like mad about it or like any sort of like anger because I've experienced that in the past with people that I've been in like situationships with and I've talked about
太棒了。比如昨晚他跟我说完全不用担心，他说：“哦，我觉得你的一些粉丝在领英（LinkedIn）上找到我了。”我说：“我在Instagram上关注了大约3000人。而且我甚至根本不用领英。所以我不知道他们是怎么做到的，但大家真的很聪明。”总之，当时我坐在酒吧里简直惊呆了，听他说着“哦，好像有几个人在领英上找到我了”。但他说话的语气一点都不是在显摆，而只是在陈述事实，就像在说“事情就是这样发生的一样”。我当时还在等他为此生气呢，或者表现出任何生气的样子，因为我在过去经历过那种情况——和我处于“友达以上恋人未满”状态的人，而我还把这些谈论
on the internet and he goes oh I think it's you know it is what it is these these people are super sleuths like he's like just you know treating everything like it's just another day I don't want to worry about that with him which has always been something that I've like held my breath like I went on a date actually very conveniently very funny at the exact same bar that I went on my first date with my boyfriend in same bar with a guy who I met actually in a more, you know, romantic way. Like, we met out, and he, like, came up and asked for my number and, you know, did that whole thing. And we went to this bar, had drinks, and we're talking about other things.
到了互联网上。而他说：“哦，我觉得吧，事情就是这样，这也没办法，这届网友简直是超级侦探。”他就像这样，把一切都当成稀松平常的事来对待。我再也不用在他面前提心吊胆了，而这在我过去总是让我感到窒息。有一次我约会，说来也巧，非常搞笑的是，约会的地点竟然和我跟现男友第一次约会的酒吧是同一家。就是那家酒吧，而那个约会对象是我以一种更浪漫的方式认识的。我们在外面偶遇，他主动走过来要了我的电话号码，你知道的，就是那一套流程。我们去了那家酒吧，喝了酒，聊着其他各种事情。
And then all of a sudden he's like, oh, so what do you for work? And I was like, oh, explaining my career. And he goes, oh, I'm sorry. You were perfect till he said that you're an influencer. I can't date an influencer. He pays a check, walks out, literally. But how it's so interesting, so it's the same bar that I met my now boyfriend in. A year later, a year and a half,ish later.
然后突然之间，他问：“哦，那你平时是做什么工作的？”我说：“哦。”然后解释了我的职业。结果他说：“哦，真遗憾。你本来完美无缺，直到你说了你是个网红。我不能跟网红约会。”他直接付了账单，起身就走，真的就这么走了。但这件事多么有意思啊，那竟然是我和我现在的男朋友相识的同一家酒吧。一年后，或者说一年半左右之后。
Yeah. Yeah. So, of course, that's something that I'm guarded in that way. Yeah. I'm like, oof, I want to protect my one first love, my first love being the podcast. Yeah. Yeah. YouTube, actually, YouTube being the first love because podcast is more recent.
对，对。所以，当然了，我在这方面会有所戒备。对，我会想，噢，我要保护我的初恋——我的初恋就是这个播客。对。对，YouTube，其实YouTube才是初恋，因为播客更晚一些。
But, you know. Same thing. The community almost. Like, no, yes. Like my girls. My people. My people. Like, come on.
但，你知道的。差不多是一回事。社群差不多。就像，不，对。就像我的女孩们。我的人。我的人。拜托。
You think that you'll ever come first? I have all these girls that have been with me since 2009. Like absolutely not, honey. It's not happening. So interesting, though, like, I'm going to refer to another Taylor's Swift song here, which is Invisible String, which is like how interesting that you went on that date with that person who, by the way, dodged a bullet because if anyone ever said that to me, I would be incredibly upset. But also actually, I would just lose all respect for them.
你觉得你会把什么放在第一位吗？我有这些从2009年就一直陪着我的女孩。绝对不可能，亲爱的。这不会发生。不过太有趣了，就像，我要在这里引用泰勒·斯威夫特的另一首歌，那就是《Invisible String》，多有趣啊，你和那个人约会，顺便说一句，他真的是逃过一劫，因为如果有人对我说那种话，我会极其难过。而且事实上，我甚至会对他彻底失去尊重。
Like, what do you do? Narrow-minded. I mean, he was a finance. Finance, bro, classic, just, like, thinks that all influencers are, like, boneheads, which, come on. Actually, we have a lot of street smarts and book smarts to be able to do something like this. Yeah, you're running your own business. You are entire, you're paying your own bills.
就像，你该怎么办？思想狭隘。我是说，他是搞金融的。金融男，经典，就是觉得所有网红都是笨蛋，拜托。事实上，我们有很多街头智慧和书本智慧，才能做成这样的事情。是的，你在经营自己的生意。你是完全独立的，你在自己付账单。
You have to think about brand management, marketing, the future. If you work in finance, someone's going to tell you what to do day in and day out. Like, I'm sorry to say it. Like, and I think that's... I wish you were there to tell him that. I know that your current boyfriend works in finance, but he does not count. He is... Yeah, no.
你必须考虑品牌管理、市场营销、未来。如果你在金融界工作，每天都会有人告诉你该做什么。真是不好意思这么说。而且我认为那是……我真希望当时你在场去告诉他。我知道你现在的男朋友是做金融的，但他不算。他是……是的，算了吧。
He's different. Oh, he is different in many ways. Yeah. But it's that invisible string, right? Where it's like, only in hindsight can you look back and be like, all of those things that felt really terrible at the time and that were really disappointing had to happen. to get me to this point. And so I really think that when I think in this,
他是不同的。哦，他在很多方面都不同。是的。但这就是那根无形的线，对吧？只有在事后回顾时，你才会觉得，当时感觉糟糕透顶、让人极其失望的所有事情，都是为了让我走到这一步而必须发生的。所以，当我想到这一点时，你知道的
you know, when I'm talking to people who have never had a relationship, have had their hearts broken a lot of times, wonder if they'll ever find someone, it's only with hindsight that you see how everything, and I know it sounds awful, but does happen for a reason, or that if you're happy with your current self,
当我跟那些从未谈过恋爱、受过很多次情伤、怀疑自己是否能找到另一半的人聊天时，只有在事后，你才会明白一切——我知道这听起来很糟糕——确实事出有因，或者说，如果你对现在的自己感到满意，
you can't be mad at your past self because that all of those things needed to happen to get you there. be a completely different person, perhaps a lot less happy if those painful things maybe hadn't happened previously. I completely agree. Like every past version of myself has kind of been, like I picture it being like, you know, when you put your hands together and someone, you can like launch someone up over a fence like that. Like that's, I picture it like a chain of like Katie's with different hair colors because I've gone through many phases. Just like boosting, boosting me up until I've gotten to meet this incredible guy that I know with, you know.
你就不能生过去的自己的气，因为所有这些事情的发生都是为了引领你走到今天。如果没有那些痛苦的经历，你可能会成为一个完全不同的人，甚至可能没那么快乐。我完全同意。就像过去的每一个自己，我都把它想象成，你知道的，就像你把双手扣在一起，别人可以踩着你的手翻过栅栏那样。就像那样，我把它想象成一串不同发色的凯蒂，因为我经历过很多阶段。一直在支撑着我，把我托举起来，直到我遇到了这个我所认识的了不起的家伙……
And it's it's been a journey because I just have trusted my gut the whole time. Even if even in the times where like it's been kind of hard, like I've let people go that ended up being like, you know, I think back to this one particular, which was kind of like my first. I have never been in love like to this at this point in time. Like I feel like I could get there with this current guy. I'm not rushing things. I really like him a lot. But of course, I'm like, you know, I'm trying to be slow and steady and listen to myself and not rush into things. But my first, like, time getting close to feeling that way was with this situation ship guy that I, you know, started in college. I met this guy in high school. And it ended up being one of those
这一路走来不容易，因为我自始至终都相信自己的直觉。即使在那些有点艰难的时刻，我也曾放手过那些最终……你知道的，回想起这段特别的经历，它有点像是我的初恋。我以前从来没有爱到这种程度，在这个时间点。我觉得我跟现在的这个男生可能会走到那一步。我并不急于求成。我真的很喜欢他。但当然，你知道的，我试着稳扎稳步，倾听内心的声音，不急于求成。不过我第一次差点有这种感觉，是在大学时认识的那个“暧昧对象”身上。我是在高中认识这个家伙的。
things where, like, he was a few years younger than me. But in college, we like continue to talk. Every time I come home, it was like one of those like hometown romances. And I was, like, I was the one long story short I was the one to end that because I just didn't feel like there was a spark like I didn't feel like we had chemistry I mean he was like a he was a really interesting guy very cool guy but I felt like specifically sexually we just didn't have chemistry like it just it always felt like wrong and awkward and just not like loving it all so I ended that with him like kind of slow faded him out to be honest with you and of course I opened Facebook like a year ago and he proposed to his current girlfriend and Paris and he proposed to his current girlfriend and Paris and And there's that moment where you're like, that could have been me, you know, if I wasn't so darn picky. And then you start to second guess your decisions. And I'm like, wow, like if I had only. But then you think, no, no, no, you got to trust that past version of yourself because
结果就是，他比我小几岁。但在大学里，我们继续保持联系。每次我回家，这就变成了一段家乡恋情。长话短说，我是那个主动结束这段关系的人，因为我实在感觉不到火花，我觉得我们之间没有化学反应。我的意思是，他是一个非常有趣的家伙，非常酷的家伙，但我觉得尤其是在身体接触方面，我们完全没有化学反应——总是感觉不对劲、很尴尬，一点也没有爱的感觉。所以我和他结束了这段关系，说实话，我算是慢慢疏远了他。当然，大约一年前我打开Facebook，发现他在巴黎向现任女友求婚了，他在巴黎向现任女友求婚了，然后
she knew what she was doing for her in that moment. And it's all led you here. Even if you feel like you're, you know, sitting here empty handed. No, like it's for the best. Like that could have ended in, you know, what if. we were getting engaged in Paris right now. Like we could get divorced next year. Yeah.
就会有那么一刻，你会觉得，如果我不是那么挑剔的话，那个人可能就是我了。然后你开始对自己的决定产生怀疑。我会想，哇，如果我当时……但接着你会想，不，不，不，你必须相信过去的那个自己，因为
And that's not what I want to set myself up for. I mean, it happens inevitably sometimes, but like you don't want to set yourself up for that just by settling, you know? I totally agree. And it's also I think about the people who, when you said that story, like I think about the people who I, who I really mourned and who moved on and I wish that I had been with and I wish that they'd love me and I wish that I hadn't let them go. And now I'm like, and at the time, I was like, oh my God. I miss them so much. Now I think about them in hindsight and I'm like, can I, can you imagine having
她在当时为自己做出了正确的选择。这一切都引领你走到了这里。即使你觉得自己好像两手空空地坐在这里。不，这其实是最好的安排。这本来可能会以……万一我们现在正在巴黎订婚呢。我们明年可能就离婚了。是的。
children with those people? Can you imagine, imagine having to, you know, manage finances with them. Imagine taking them on a family vacation. Like, absolutely not. Imagine having sex with them for the rest of your life. Literally, that's what I was thinking of. I'm like, but Katie, remember why you left. Remember why it didn't work out? And that's that. Yeah, you do find yourself morning. because you selectively forget all the bad stuff. Oh, yeah. It's like, again, Taylor Swift, she's like, I'm over you until I forget why I needed to be over you or whatever that line is.
这不是我想要的人生开局。我的意思是，有时候这在所难免，但你不想仅仅因为凑合就给自己设定这种开局，对吧？我完全同意。而且我也想到了那些人，当你讲那个故事时，我想到了那些我曾真心为之悲伤过、后来他们继续了生活、我曾希望自己能和他们在一起、希望他们爱我、希望当初没有放手的人。现在我想，当时我觉得，天哪，我太想念他们了。现在事后回想起来，我在想，你能想象和那些人
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Or I stopped calling you and then I forget why I needed to stop. You know, you forget, but you don't, but you do. You know, it's one of those things. It's like actually this thing. It's called like positive retrospection. So like when we look back at our past, our brain often like suppresses the bad things and keeps all the good stuff because it wants us to like yeah it wants us to be optimistic it wants to protect our self-esteem it wants to protect our mood
生孩子吗？你能想象，想象必须和他们一起管理财务吗？想象带他们去家庭度假。绝对不行。想象和他们过一辈子夫妻生活。真的，我当时就是这么想的。我在想，但是凯蒂，记住你为什么要离开。记住为什么这段关系行不通？事情就是这样。是的，你会发现自己在悲伤，因为你有选择性地遗忘所有糟糕的事情。哦，是的。这就像，还是泰勒·斯威夫特，她说，我放下了你，直到我忘了我为什么要放下你，或者类似这样的一句歌词。
and so when you look back at a relationship and you can only remember the good things that is that is that is why that is why it's because your brain is like playing tricks on you to make sure that you continue to be positively reinforced and don't like end up in a deep duck Give up. Yeah. Yeah. Literally. I mean, it's a blessing and a curse, huh? Yeah, absolutely. Might repeat past mistakes, but yeah. You learn them a few times over and they're really reinforced. You double dip. Yeah, literally. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
对，对，对。或者我不再给你打电话，然后我忘了我为什么要停止。你知道的，你忘记了，但你又没忘，其实你记得。你知道，这就是那种情况。这其实叫作“积极回顾”。所以当我们回顾过去时，我们的大脑往往会压抑坏事，保留所有美好的东西，因为它希望我们——是的，它希望我们保持乐观，它想保护我们的自尊，它想保护我们的心情
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental top. toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will kind of,
所以当你回首一段恋情，却只能想起美好的事情时，这就是原因所在，这就是为什么，因为你的大脑在跟你玩心理把戏，确保你继续得到积极的强化，而不至于陷入深深的绝望而放弃。对。对。真的。我的意思是，这既是福也是祸，对吧？是的，绝对是。可能会重复过去的错误，但对，你从中学到了几次，而且得到了很深刻的强化。你梅开二度。对，真的。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可供选择时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，心理韧性、体能和构建复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起发炎。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你某种程度上就会
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
在另一端，变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即HeartRadio应用、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方搜索TWO Percent。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。玩蠢游戏，赢蠢奖品。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女友们》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾和同一个惯犯骗手约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以她们决定亲自采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉尔·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉尔·金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊当天的可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上台面了，所以。谢谢你把话说完。
We get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
对。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，与众多优秀的嘉宾进行对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have. have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. You live in New York. I feel like that's a dream for a lot of people. You work for yourself. You have the three things Carrie Bradshaw was always looking for. An apartment, a boyfriend, a job.
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
But I think it's really interesting. Another thing in our 20s that people ask me about, quite a bit is moving to a new city and how to build community. And I'm wondering if you could speak to that, especially since you're in one of the biggest cities in the world. How do you build community? How do you make new friends? How do you find a home in a new place? Yeah.
绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地去成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。你住在纽约。我觉得这对很多人来说都是个梦想。你为自己工作。你拥有了凯莉·布拉德肖一直在寻找的三样东西：一套公寓、一个男朋友、一份工作。
I mean, I definitely consider myself to be one of those like introverted extroverts where I, I'm good with people. I'm good with like with new people. but I have to be in the mood and my battery dies quick. It's like that's how I feel. And so moving to New York, I was actually the first of, very fortunately a lot of my friends also ended up getting jobs here right out of college. I moved here a month after I graduated college.
但我觉得这真的很有趣。我们在二十多岁时，人们经常问我的另一件事就是搬到一个新城市以及如何建立社群。我想知道你是否能谈谈这一点，特别是考虑到你正身处世界上最大的城市之一。你如何建立社群？你如何结交新朋友？你如何在新的地方找到归属感？是的。
I'd gotten a corporate job. They wanted me here, so it actually worked out perfectly. But a bunch of my friends lived in New Jersey. So they were just commuting in, taking the ferry into the city, still living at home, saving money. but I am from Maryland, so it's a little bit too far of a commute, so I just, I needed to move here, and I needed to move here fast. So I picked like the cheapest, you know, decently close to my, my job apartment I could find in Hell's Kitchen, ended up being mouse-infested, coffersed,
我的意思是，我绝对认为自己是那种内向的外向者，我擅长与人交往。我擅长结识新朋友。但我必须得有心情，而且我的电量消耗得很快。这就是我的感受。所以搬到纽约时，我很幸运，我的很多朋友大学一毕业也都在这里找到了工作。我大学毕业一个月后就搬到了这里。
oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, but I grew in, like, if that didn't scare me out of New York, like, you know, you know you belong here, if that. That was my first, I felt like, you know, I was in never grow up, Taylor Swift, like, I tuck myself in and turn the nightlight on. Like, that was me, like, every night for, like, the first, like, three months until, like, people started visiting me at least. So I had to, you know, cultivate a sort of community fast because I, being this, like, introverted, extrooted person, like, I definitely need people or I tend to go insane, especially. I mean, this was when I was still at my corporate job, so I had, like, a bunch of, I had
我找到了一份公司的工作。他们需要我来这里，所以一切都进行得非常完美。但我的很多朋友住在新泽西。所以他们只是通勤进城，坐渡轮进城，依然住在家里，存钱。不过我来自马里兰州，所以通勤距离有点太远了，我必须搬到这里，而且必须快点搬。所以我找了地狱厨房里我能找到的、离我工作地点最近、最便宜的公寓，结果里面满是老鼠，还有臭虫，
co-workers, thank God. I don't know how I would have done this, like, this current free. Lance life that I live in my first year. Like, it was tough because I was also young. I was, you know, fresh out of college, like, had lived with my sorority house, like, really recently. Like, I was just used to having, like, girls around all the time. So it was hard to adjust.
哦，是的。哦，是的，但我在成长，如果那没有把我吓得离开纽约，你知道的，你就知道你属于这里。那是我第一次，我感觉，你知道的，我就像在泰勒·斯威夫特的歌里《never grow up》，我把自己塞进被窝，打开小夜灯。那就是我，大概头三个月里每天晚上都是这样，直到至少有人开始来看望我。所以我必须，你知道的，迅速建立某种社群，因为作为这样一个内向的外向的人，我绝对需要人陪，否则我往往会发疯，特别是。我的意思是，当时我还在公司上班，所以我有一群，我有
But I think, like, my biggest piece of advice or, like, strategy, I did a lot of sliding into people's DMs on Instagram. Interesting. And I still do. And I have no shame. Like, I find. people in so many different ways. I mean, TikTok makes it so easy now because also they give you, like, they kind of feed you
同事，谢天谢地。我不知道如果像现在这样过着自由职业的生活，我第一年要怎么熬过来。这太艰难了，因为我也很年轻。我，你知道的，刚大学毕业，不久前还住在姐妹会的房子里。我只是习惯了身边总是有女孩们。所以很难适应。
people in your area. Like, I get a lot of New York content on TikTok. I don't know if everyone gets that, but like I think, like, when I'm home in Maryland, they get Maryland content. Yeah, yeah. I get city content. I think TikTok knows these things. Right.
但我认为，我最大的建议或策略是，我在Instagram上私信过很多人。很有趣。我到现在还这么做。我一点也不觉得不好意思。我通过各种各样的方式寻找朋友。我的意思是，TikTok现在让这一切变得太简单了，因为他们也会为你提供，他们会主动给你推荐
So, like, you can kind of find, and especially with TikTok, you can find kind of like, you know, micro creators as well, like people that are just, you know, everyday people that are just posting their outfits, which, like, I love that. I follow a ridiculous amount of people on TikTok now that just for like outfit content. My God, really? That aren't like your typical influencer, but they're influencing me. So I would find someone like that. I mean, back, you know, just on Instagram and whatever.
所以，你可以找到，特别是在TikTok上，你可以找到那种，你知道的，微型创作者，就像那些只是，你知道的，普通人在发他们的穿搭，这，就像，我很喜欢。我现在在TikTok上关注了数量惊人的仅仅发布穿搭内容的人。天哪，真的吗？他们不像是典型的网红，但他们在影响我。所以我会找到这样的人。我的意思是，以前，你知道的，只在Instagram上或者别的什么地方。
And I was just like DM and be like, hey, like I love your outfit here. I love your vibe. Whatever. Literally slide in and be like, do you want to get coffee or drinks and whatever? The worst thing they can do is like open it, not reply. You know, just say, yeah, sure, but never coordinate a time. it's kind of like a dating app. Like you're not always going to get a hit, but you actually, you might.
然后我就会发私信说，嘿，我很喜欢你这里的穿搭。我喜欢你的氛围。诸如此类的。直接滑入私信说，你想去喝杯咖啡或喝一杯吗？无论如何。他们能做的最糟的事就是打开它，不回复。你知道的，就说，好啊，当然，但从不协调时间。这有点像约会软件。就像你不会每次都配对成功，但实际上，你可能会。
I mean, I've actually met people recently that have told me that they've used Bumble BFF as well to do a very similar thing. It's like if you don't want to, if you don't feel comfortable doing it over on TikTok on on Instagram, BFF, like you can find friends that way. And I think the thing about New York is people are always, you know, I at least personally feel people are always willing to expand their circle because it's not like, You know, it's, oh, hey, let's meet at this bar at 7 p.m. Or, like, this restaurant.
我的意思是，我最近确实遇到了一些人，他们告诉我他们也用过Bumble BFF来做非常类似的事情。这就好像如果你不想，如果你在TikTok或Instagram上觉得这样做不舒服，Bumble BFF，你可以用那种方式找到朋友。而且我认为关于纽约的一点是人们总是，你知道的，我至少个人觉得人们总是愿意扩大他们的社交圈，因为这不像，你知道的，哦，嘿，我们晚上7点在这家酒吧见面。或者，像，这家餐厅。
It's, like, it's easy, I think, because we're all kind of close together, like sandwiched together here, at least. But at any place, I mean, BFF is a great way to do it. Just shamelessly sliding into DMs. Like, I think it's the most fun story that, like, a few of my friends that I'm very close with now. I'm like, oh, yeah, Katie slid in my DMs. Like, they're like, Katie, yeah, I did.
这，就像，这很简单，我认为因为我们都靠得很近，就像在这里被夹在一起一样，至少是这样。但在任何地方，我的意思是，Bumble BFF是一个好方法。就是毫无羞耻地滑入私信。就像，我认为这是最有趣的笑话，就像我现在的几个非常要好的朋友。我会说，哦，对了，凯蒂滑入了我的私信。就像，他们会说，凯蒂，对，我确实这么做了。
No shame. Absolutely no shame. And then through that, I've actually, I joined a book club through that. Like, yeah, you just got to get your foot in the door. And it's really not awkward. It's not, like, you might feel like it is. But everyone, everyone's just trying to, like, find their people, especially in a big city. Because, like, big cities are the places where you can feel the most lonely.
毫无羞耻。绝对毫无羞耻。然后通过那个，我其实，我通过那个加入了一个读书俱乐部。就像，是的，你只需要迈出第一门槛。而且真的不尴尬。不是说，你可能会觉得是这样。但每个人，每个人都只是在试图，你知道的，找到属于他们的人，特别是在大城市。因为，大城市正是最让人感到孤独的地方。
Totally. You know, surrounded by people. Yeah. spot on. I think that's so spot on. One more I'm going to add to that list, which I'm sure you did. Ask to be friendship set up as well. So like when I... Ooh. Yeah. Tell me more about that. This is like something that happened to me when I moved to Sydney. So like Sydney is the biggest city in Australia and not as big as New York. It's still tiny. But I moved from Canberra, which is like no one knows where that is. It's like a tiny. It's like our capital city. It's tiny. and I really didn't know anyone and I wasn't working.
完全同意。你知道的，被人群包围。是的。说得太对了。我认为真的太对了。我还要往那个清单上加一条，我确信你也做过。请求别人帮你牵线搭桥交朋友。所以就像当我……哦。是的。多跟我讲讲这个。这就像我搬到悉尼时发生在我身上的事。所以悉尼是澳大利亚最大的城市，虽然没有纽约那么大。它还是很小。但我从堪培拉搬过去，那是个没人知道在哪儿的地方。它就像个小镇。就像我们的首都。它很小。我真的谁也不认识，而且我当时没工作。
And so the first, and I had just gone through a breakup. So it was just like I was like peak loneliness. And I like messaged one of my friends and I was like, do you have any people who live in Sydney who you think I would like? And she was like, as a matter of fact, I do. And she put us both into a group chat together was like, I think you two would be friends and then left the group chat. And so we were kind of awkwardly there being like, do we get a drink?
所以首先，我刚刚经历了一次分手。所以那就像我处于孤独的顶峰。我给我的一位朋友发了信息，我说，你在悉尼有认识什么你觉得我会喜欢的其他人吗？她就说，事实上，我还真有。她把我们俩拉进了一个群聊，然后说，我觉得你们俩会成为朋友，接着就退出了群聊。所以我们有点尴尬地呆在那里，心想，我们要去喝一杯吗？
And we were like, yeah, let's do it. And this is like, like, flash forward, fast forward, I guess. This, like, friend of mine, like, came on my family vacation with me last year. Like, had New Year's and Christmas at my house. And I'd known her for, like, seven months. And it was like, I just met like a soulmate. So you never know. You never know.
然后我们就说，好吧，我们去吧。这就好像，快进，快进，我猜。这个，我的朋友，去年和我一起去了我的家庭度假。就像在我家过了新年和圣诞节。我认识她大概才七个月。就好像，我刚刚遇到一个灵魂伴侣。所以你永远不知道。你永远不知道。
They just come out of the woodwork and you're like, how can we, how come I've never met you before? Like, right. What was I doing? And then you can't imagine your life without them. Like, it's like. Genuinely. And you wouldn't. of and then you have that moment of being proud of yourself, which I think life is all about just
他们突然冒出来，你会想，怎么会，我以前怎么从来没见过你？就像，对的。我以前在干嘛？然后你就无法想象没有他们的生活。就像是。真的。而且你不会。并且你会有那种为自己感到骄傲的时刻，我认为生活就是关于
like finding reasons or creating reasons for you to feel proud of yourself. Yeah. You know, taking risks, doing things that like require a lot of bravery. Life is all about just like collecting those moments. So like when you're at a low point, you just sit here and think, wait a second, though. Like I maybe I, this is something bad that's happening to me and I'm like not feeling my best right now. But look at all the stuff that I've done.
寻找理由或创造理由让你为自己感到骄傲。是的。你知道的，冒险，做那些需要极大勇气的事情。生活就是关于收集那些时刻。所以当处于低谷时，你只是坐在这里想，等一下。就像我可能，这是一件发生在我身上的坏事，我现在感觉不是最好状态。但看看我做过的所有事情。
Look at all the times that like I went out there and tried, even if it wasn't, reciprocated even if it didn't work out and like look at all look at the life that I've created for myself feel the fear and do it anyways right like you've just got to amen I love that saying I know we're like me too it's a pump up episode I'm like life advice you're going to get it all even if you didn't ask for it unsolicited well I want to thank you so much for coming on the show I of course and I would really I just want to plug all your content I'm going to say this I was watching Katie's YouTube channel when I was in high school. And it was so funny because you went to like university like two years before me, college, sorry. And I was like, oh, this looks fun. Like,
看看我所有那些走出去尝试的时刻，即使它没有得到回应，即使它没有成功，然后看看所有，看看我为自己创造的生活，感受恐惧并依然去做，对吧？你只需要——太棒了，我很喜欢这句话，我知道我们就像——我也是，这是一个打气的一集，我就像人生建议，你都会得到，即使你没有主动要求，不请自来的建议。好吧，我非常感谢你来到节目，当然，我真的只想宣传你的所有内容。我要这么说，我上高中时就在看凯蒂的YouTube频道。太搞笑了，因为你比我早大概两年上大学，大学，抱歉。我就想，哦，这看起来挺好玩的，就像，
I'm going to go to a campus and like go to a dorm and like do all these things. And so I feel like it's just like big sister advice. You always providing me with the big sister advice. And I really think that your content is so evergreen and beautiful and inclusive and warm and very like, pretty. I know that sounds so weird. Pretty. I feel like I ended on a bad one. Beautiful. I like pretty. Pretty is a good word. It's just, it's good. It's probably top of mind, summer I turn pretty, you know. Yeah, that's what I was thinking. So where can they find you if they want to hear more from you? Sure. You can just type my name into most social media platforms and I have some sort of footprint there. It's Katie with a Y. Don't mess it up like my boyfriend did the first time.
我要去大学校园，去宿舍，做所有这些事情。所以我觉得这就像是大姐姐的忠告。你总是向我提供大姐姐的忠告。而且我真的认为你的内容是如此长青、美好、包容、温馨，而且非常，漂亮。我知道这听起来很奇怪。漂亮。我觉得我以一个不太好的词结尾了。美好。我喜欢漂亮。漂亮是个好词。这可能是最受关注的词，我变漂亮的夏天，你知道的。是的，这也是我所想的。所以如果他们想听你分享更多，在哪里可以找到你？当然。你只要在大多数社交媒体平台上输入我的名字，我在那里就都有某种足迹。是凯蒂，带个Y。别像我男朋友第一次那样搞砸了。
K-A-T-Y-B-E-L-L-O-T-E. Belotti pronounced like Pilates, but spelled B-E-L-L-O-T-E. Type that in most everywhere. I have this podcast called Match Made in Manhattan, which is like my newest baby with my two best friends. We talk actually like in-depth. We share way too much on there. Every episode ends up being explicit rating.
K-A-T-Y-B-E-L-L-O-T-E。Belotti，发音像Pilates（普拉提），但是拼写是B-E-L-L-O-T-E。几乎到处都输入这个。我有一个播客叫Match Made in Manhattan，这就像是我和我两个最好朋友的最新宝贝。我们其实在里面进行了深入的交谈。我们在那里面分享得太多了。每一集最后都被评为限制级。
We produce, it self-produced, self-film, and record in my apartment every week. and you guys should definitely check it out because we talk about the ups and downs of dating. It's really, really good. It's people always ask me what podcasts I listen to. Imagine Miami Manhattan. That's my background podcast. No, it's so great.
我们制作，是自主制作，每周在我的公寓里自己拍摄和录制。你们绝对应该去看看，因为我们谈论约会的起起伏伏。真的，真的很好。人们总是问我听什么播客。Match Made in Manhattan。那是我的背景播客。不，这太棒了。
It's so weird being like asking your questions about yourself as if I didn't hear it on the podcast. It's so awkward. But I want to thank you again for coming on board. And as always, if you enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify. wherever you're listening right now, if someone needs to hear this episode, if someone needs to hear Katie's wisdom, my wisdom as well, I guess.
问关于你自己的问题感觉好奇怪，就像我没在播客里听过一样。太尴尬了。但我还是要再次感谢你来参加节目。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify上留下五星好评，无论你在哪里收听，如果有人需要听这一集，如果有人需要听凯蒂的智慧，还有我的智慧，我想。请把这一集分享给他们。如果你有任何播客建议，请关注That Psychology Podcast发送给我们。一如既往，谢谢大家，我们下周见。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
Please send them this episode. And if you have an episode's suggestion, follow us at That Psychology Podcast to send it through there. Thank you as always, and we will be back next week. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的姿态从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即IHeartRadio应用上的TWO%，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app,
Apple Podcasts，或者任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并尝试弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家一起度过难关的。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并尝试弄清楚我们是如何与朋友、喜剧同行和最喜欢的作家一起度过难关的。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔在80年代那样。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，大家好！你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师
and hosts care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast,
兼主持人Carey主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做，在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客上收听《Learn the Hard Way》
or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini.
或任何你获取播客的地方。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲，但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。